that's our pretty view for Hannah they
haven't seen the movie yet that's pretty
much the whole soundtrack and you just
keep on playing that on Pete and yeah
okay just get off harpsichord and throw
it down a flight of stairs while playing
a violin you don't know how to play hi
I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Jerry and I'm
Thomas welcome the reasons to see where
we give you reasons to see insidious
chapter 2 I don't reason to see number 1
Patrick Wilson does not get naked in
this move no he does not get naked Mary
that's son of a [ __ ] you almost got
naked in the first one he was in his
underwear I was like okay but no cuz he
if he has no no Patrick Wilson he's
always shirtless or naked it looks good
too yeah he doesn't look real good I
mean he should be that that was the one
thing missing from his performance in
this film it is almost Jack Nicholson
from The Shining performance no Patrick
Wilson's awesome in this movie like he's
totally different than the first one
technically plays two people in this
file he's good at carrying on and
continuing the character we saw from the
first one and this new character is
terrifying at times just absolutely
scary and his performance is awesome you
come back to him and you're not sure if
he's okay because the events of the
first film and then he's really good at
giving you a sense that something is off
over you know long periods of time and
then when he finally gets to go nuts he
commits hard to that well if you think
about it like the first one really is
about him like it's kind of deceitful
away cuz and in a smart way because it's
like they make it seem like it's about
the boy no really the story is strongly
about Patrick Wilson's character and
that's why chapter 2 continues it with
mainly being the struggle in like not
internally
I don't know spirit in the spirit yeah
yeah yeah I struggle between the spirit
world in the corporeal world yeah
fighting
I love how because we saw the double
feature that they were in case you guys
didn't know there's a double feature
you've missed out if you didn't see it
sorry
I remember watching that moment where
Patrick Wilson's like I'm not afraid of
you he's talking to the scary old lady
I'm not afraid of you I'm not afraid of
you and I'm like yeah character growth
here we came and then and he gets [ __ ]
over right trying to confront his fear
so never confront your fears right from
this it was totally reminded me a lot of
like Jack Nicholson's descent in in the
shiny there's a lot of scary movies that
have that work the bad thing happens to
the father figure in the movie like
Amityville Horror if you take the strong
person out of the family and turn them
against the family it's a little scarier
because yeah it's really you know women
can't do anything yeah woman a week so
are puny and then the kids know they're
good yeah who saves the day all the time
it's the sciences it's usually guys it's
the man's a guy testosterone mm-hmm can
woman you know fly in their dreams
no but men can I'm just gonna point out
that Elise was pretty instrumental in
the first movie and if she hadn't come
but did you don't want even to say that
she saved the day find uh I believe it
Patrick Wilson you supplied them with
all the tools to save him knowledge of
powers he already had that's true yeah
that she took away and chose to give
back yeah she's a [ __ ] Catherine Wilson
is a hero when you look at him for a lot
of this movie you don't think you're
watching Josh anymore even though he
looks like the same guy he feels like a
different character because of you know
what's happening inside of his body what
I liked about his performance a lot of
was you could tell he was having a lot
of fun yeah it's always great to see an
actor have a lot of fun especially like
someone who's usually so serious because
when you watch the double feature it's
it's it's actually I thought made the
experience better yes this movie
literally is just a continuation
I remember watching Patrick Wilson and I
was like he's a really serious guy and
then in the
one even though he plays like the
villain he's he's a lot of fun to watch
because he could tell he's having a good
time
well and that's the thing is is he
really gets a lot of stuff to do in both
of these movies because in the first
movie he takes a rule that's usually a
bum roll haunted house movies are sort
of famous for having the stupid dad
character and that movie avoids that and
he helps to sell that and in this movie
he gets to go nuts so yeah they've
really given him over these two films a
lot of cool things to do and to work
with despite how you feel about it you
can't you can't take for granted the
fact that for a sequel they were really
attempting to be different and not to
replicate yeah it was it was definitely
way different things are gonna get real
insidious I think that the reason to see
number two it finishes the story what I
like about this is it's a real
continuation of the first one it picks
up from where it left off it's just cool
to see like they're taking all the same
characters and put it than just
continuing what we saw it just feels
like an extended that's what you know I
mean it feels like an extend in 90
minutes or something like that a lot of
scary movie sequels they kind of try and
do the prequels ya know that's the fan
or they try and do a whole different
family this one that kind of like you
said it added to it you've got to get to
see cuz I mean the movie could have just
had to right there they didn't even need
to make a sequel it's scary because it
ends like that you don't know what's
gonna happen especially with this
particular horror sub-genre that's like
the haunted house movie sequel is a hard
thing to do because a lot of times you
get oh you know the family's being
haunted again but the house is different
you know we have different set pieces in
this movie it seems like they really
took the time and effort to be like okay
how can we make this sequel work and be
different without doing any they didn't
really have any retroactive continuity
you know they didn't have to change the
first movie to make
second movie work and that's you know a
big big respect to them for that you
know like when James won I was sharing I
was reading an interview with him and
what he said was he was trying to go for
like a domestic thriller and when I was
watching this movie that's like the
total vibe that I got it's very it
doesn't feel like haunted house anymore
it does feel like domestic thriller with
ghosts like shy yeah and it's it's cool
to see them change it up like that you
know for some people it's definitely not
gonna work and for some people you know
they might really like it well I think
they even in the first one they were
trying to stray away from the more
haunted house and they even explained
it's the child who's supposedly haunted
because all the spirits want to get into
his fun so that's why even they they
moved because remember yeah I heard that
he's trying to stay away from that
cliche of oh they always stay in the
house like they always say the house you
know if dad doesn't believe and only
it's things like that yeah so when they
moved in the first one that's when and
stuff still happened that's when you're
like okay this is a little different
than all the other haunted house movies
I've seen they really got outside the
box for this and this is a movie where
theoretically you could have just you
know rest on your laurels and just feel
like now we're gonna collect a paycheck
you could they could have easily because
the first one made so much money and it
was such a hit you know they could have
just been like yeah whatever as long as
we bring people back people we're gonna
watch it anyway but it seems like they
really took the time and effort to go
how could this story advance from what
we've seen what can we get creative with
and the whole new story with the you
know the old woman goes from the first
movie tying that in essentially kind of
does what saw to did with jigsaw it's
like you see this this sort of
villainous character we only see a
couple times in the first movie then you
take that character and you flesh them
out in a way that's completely scary for
a whole different reason yeah it feels
like that this was parts of the first
one that they didn't have time to fit in
or something like yeah you know like
it's not like they just like compiled
deleted scenes it's like no they this is
the completion of the original story
like it ties in way too well it doesn't
seem like like the tie-ins were like huh
makes a lot more sense not mmm that's a
clever trick you did you know the times
we're pretty cool it's because because
we got to see the double feature so we
got to you know kind of see
the different times that you know if we
saw the movie two years ago or whenever
it came out that we probably might not
have caught but uh like like when he was
knocking on the door I really like that
because it they they had the scenes from
the first movie showing everything that
happened and you don't really think
about you're just like oh but it's just
ghosts you know they're there in the
house and everything but then when they
tie into it so showing that he was a
part of the first movie and his astral
projection form I thought that was
really cool
there are moments they touch on in the
second movie that work in the first
movie because you don't know much about
them they're mysterious they wrap those
moments around kind of like you know
with the whole parallel timeline thing
they wrap them around and wasted really
clever and and you know some of them are
scary for different reasons so it works
for two different you know stories it's
like yeah the mystery of the first one
then you have the woe of the second one
yeah the first one has more of a does
have much more of like a mystery horror
feel and this one has like a sort of a
super much more supernatural feel about
it you know because you're really in the
other world a lot of the time you know
yeah yeah I think because you're only in
the other world in the finale of the
first one and in this one you're like
you get it you can think okay they cut
back and forth a lot and then you got
side stories going on with spec and
Tucker and yeah and Carly Carly Carly
Carly does the way they well they think
the the idea of the further and they
even expand upon that they explore it in
different ways you know with like she
says in the first movie it's it's a
distant realm but it's also all around
us so it's got that weird time crunched
in on that cell phone you know there's
kind of thing so yeah yeah and I really
appreciated that this sequel you pretty
much had to watch the first one cuz they
didn't want me to us yeah yeah a lot of
sequels nowadays they're kind of like oh
let's just do a hole in this story you
know if we need to explain something
we'll do it they didn't really explain
anything in the second one it's easy
thirty you've seen the first one that
you know it or you're completely lost
and you just hopped in on the second one
you know like calling this chapter two
is for like the best thing to call it it
does feel like oh yeah this is a chapter
two it does not a part two or some like
insidious with a clever title afterwards
yeah it's not like oh a difference if
char featuring the Lemberg family like
this is the next step in story the movie
moves differently because we already
know these people and we already know
their situation so it kind of dives
right in this is that's pretty
fast-paced and yeah yeah reasons to see
number three
cinematography James Wan likes to you
know really incorporate tracking shots
and he does them so close like you know
a lot of zoom I'm talking specifically
about those shots when people are like
walking around the house he's father
like oh the [ __ ] cooze oh yeah yeah I
love those shots oh yeah and he has a
definite visual style and this one is a
little lighter on some of the really
crazy like you know the first movie
opens with the upside down and then
we're floating through here they follow
the lines of the banister but he's
really good in all of these especially
these ghost movies he's really good at
framing things creatively and where to
hide and sort of them have scares come
from and have shadows and lightens yeah
it did have that that kind of scare
factor work not everybody catches it
right away some people in the theater
like a booth and then you see it the
last second you're like okay holy crap
like like they would show the kind of
like a figure for about a split second
kind of like not nobody realizes it's
there and then they throw everything at
you like okay we can see it now it's
certain points I almost got sort of
giallo
like Italian vibe with although they
used a lot of color of lights like
there's especially some prominent like
red light and expressionistic stuff
reason to see number four the effects
for the conjuring and I'll say it for
this movie the effects are terrifying a
lot of time being Parker crane yeah yeah
mother is she was terrifying and you saw
the dead people or [ __ ] scary and the
makeup on Patrick Wilson fantastic yeah
there's a there's a hole see me
progressively over the movie he starts
to look shittier and shittier because of
you know certain story details and they
do a good job of gradually making him
that way and then there's a scene where
he his face is actually like withering
of these old and it's very convincing
maker but i know that old age make is
hard to do all the further go it's like
i know i know some people think it's
cheesy but i personally love that sort
of weird
almost China Doll approach to the makeup
of the further ghosts you know they're
all sort of made up in an exaggerated
almost clambering sort of way with the
rosy cheeks and the pale complexion of
the rosy cheeks the exaggerated eyes you
know the lipstick you know it's got a
definite almost funhouse sort of thing
to it and I really appreciate it because
it is jarring in a completely different
way than you know rotting corpses Homer
yeah yeah yeah
to touch on the mother again it's it's
kind of hard to make a horror film where
you don't just get scared from the
things that pop out it's like the creepy
factor is much higher in this one
because usually there's a scene where
you see the mother she's it's all about
the whole backstory and she's talking to
her son and everything and then she
realizes that the ghosts are Patrick
Wilson's character is in the further and
she looks at him you see the whole face
and the makeup and her facial expression
scared the [ __ ] out of me and woman and
like they're a little too like her her
eyes start to like changin yeah and then
she comes down I know that's hard to do
that's really our instead of like a
little like oh my god you know you
imaginary giving you a [ __ ] [ __ ] like
good things were forcing me to now
imagine that reason to see number five
Steve Coulter not Colbert Coulter let's
get it straight this guy's really cool
it's kind of introduced a new kind of
like paranormal investigator kind of
thing to it so yeah but it was cool cuz
he was you could tell he was afraid yeah
so it makes it scary because Weiner was
like when Elyse is there it's like we're
fine Elyse is here very warm yeah yeah
he does it's a good point he has a very
good contrast hit her there's like more
trauma in this guy these manatees these
are the it's like Bertie he seems more
like he's drawn to this even when he
shouldn't be when he's first introduced
you kind of get this like kind of weird
feel from him like that he's afraid and
that make you even more because he tells
at least he's like oh I'm scared yes I
mean
that's what's so cool that's another
sort of clever thing I thought they
brought into this is that they have they
you know they introduced him as as our
new sort of you know authority on the
spiritual world and stuff like that
whereas Elise has a very warm comforting
presence he like you said seems a little
bit more naturally scared of these
things but the essence of his character
comes out of the fact that he's still
willing to push through that yeah and
you see that struggle growth uni like
root for the guy at the same time you
know he's a good actor too he has a lot
of moments where he has to be like
scared but cover it up but you can feel
the fear oh yeah in the same time very
good alone because that's hard to do
like you got to show the audience that
you are scared yes but you also can't
see like dude you look scared the other
guy's gonna know ok you know yeah the
whole cast is a really strong part of
this movie and he's one of the few new
you know prominent characters and he is
a welcome addition yeah yeah I didn't
feel like he's just thrown in there I
felt like he was like an essential part
of this story and he played this part
really well reason to see number 6
though music
what I will say is like a lot of horror
movies when they have music a lot of
time it's like okay it's it's silent
there's tension and then a jump scare
and then they play music and then the
music kind of calms it down for me to be
honest but in this movie when the music
starts playing you get way more scary
it's scary yes beautiful
I found myself really freaked out when
the music started my god here we go
again like you know I get really anxious
and you know the music stops and that's
when you're like kind of realizing that
something's gonna jump out or something
but it didn't really happen like that
all the time the music's stopped and
then chill like go around and then the
music kind of start up again and boom
it'll freakin hit you with whatever
they're gonna throw out and I I didn't
appreciate that cuz that's good the [ __ ]
out of me yeah [ __ ] yeah and the you
know I'm not don't want to see a scary
movie to get the [ __ ] scared out of me
uh-huh I don't know what I'm gonna see
why did you [ __ ] take me that no I
wanted to see you [ __ ] anyway Sidious
did I use it right don't know if I know
what it means either part of what I dig
so much about both of these movies is
that all the parts are unique to these
two movies and the music is known is no
different the music has a personality
that is of the insidious world and they
carry that over into this movie that is
very gothic and shrill and discordant
and the music is you know over-the-top
but in a in an awesome way because it's
so queasy and you know again going back
to that funhouse vibe it is like it's
not subtle in the best wedding well I
think the music was probably the main
thing that set the tone throughout the
whole movie just a title card of
insidious yeah that right is terrifying
just the title car the title card is
scary you know what's coming because if
you see the first one you're like oh
okay they got me yeah you're not gonna
get me [ __ ] you got me again yeah all
right sons of [ __ ] reasons not to see
some weak writing I think sums in
understatement I think you're a son of a
[ __ ] well that's good yeah I thought
the writing and this wasn't a strong hit
like there's just some things I thought
were kind of stupid like any hand okay
whether like when the kids like mom I
could save him just
if I fall asleep I can see it just leaps
all the sudden like kids is gonna go
into hibernation I wouldn't actually
necessarily pin that on this the script
in its execution so much is like we
don't have time for this just get him to
sleep like that seems like he's not come
out you know it is implausible but this
movie is much more over-the-top I feel
like that's more of an editorial choice
though it's like we can't have ass
sitting there for 20 minutes I didn't
like how they incorporated the like the
detective like they they start off the
movie with this detective these kind of
vanishes from the movie and then they
call back is like you know it's not your
husband's but we're still [ __ ] what's a
murderer a suspected murderer out of
jail
you hold them in jail you know let's go
back to my family know if they kept them
in [ __ ] jail there won't be a movie
all right and we would've been fine I
would have done the [ __ ] scared out of
me this is the thing I feel like the
first movie is really tight I'm like
this is a really tight movie it breathes
just right the second movie to me I
think they do some great story stuff
there's some awesome twists there's some
awesome really outta left field ideas
they bring in the story is great I feel
like just as a whole the script is just
rougher around the edges in the first
movie and it feels like if they had just
gotten a little more time to smooth out
that script it would have been a better
film overall but then one can also say
like how it's a little rough kind of
adds to the chaoticness in a way yeah in
a way it sort of is it a good addition
you know like the script still doesn't
feel like it may mean it's not the most
polished but there's something about it
that does feel spontaneous there's
something about the script that does
still feel fresh so I wanted to say some
weak writing not yeah not the writing in
general just something there is a good
amount of scenes where I cut myself just
laughing just that how how kind of
cliche it was and overuse yeah
like okay when they wouldn't they were
like oh we gotta go to the you know our
Lady Angel or whatever the hospital is
yeah let's go to an abandoned [ __ ]
where every other scary movie is set I
guess it criticism but I feel like there
are so many other things this movie does
that are not cliche yeah it's just like
they're always gonna be a few yeah when
Joshua is knocking down the door
you know The Shining that's that's what
came to my mind bridge how many Bell
[ __ ] yeah and then we'll four were
also you know it is kind of kind of
distracting me it kind of brought me out
of the movie or the film because I
started just laughing I go wow like he's
gonna stick his head through and say
here's Johnny you know it's just it kind
of pissed me off and what really threw
me out was that stupid voice over in the
beginning I just wanted to make sure I
planned that out that thing pissed me
off and that just threw off the whole
the whole bruising movie for me because
they they do kind like a prequel thing
and then they introduce Elise and she
has the same voice it's a different
activities they lublin Shaye's voice
yeah for a younger actress and it was
just really really shittily done I'm
making a fort with the movie like this a
lot of times I'll go in a movie I'll be
like that was kind of choppy you know
I'm interested to see how I feel on a
second pass because not all the time and
a lot of the time when I see a movie
that seems a little like oh this is kind
of a mess at the beginning a lot of
times it's not as much so on a couple
other passes we're going to sort of pick
out all the small details so I'm just
interested to see how to play a second
time but yeah me too split decision
number one fun scares like cheap scarce
funds sugarcoating it so he doesn't like
though the cheap [ __ ] scared right I
like more in the movie well since I
don't like it I'll begin I hate [ __ ]
cheap scares first person camera
shooting and then it steps on something
going everyone freaks out it's just a
little doll on the ground somebody's
putting putting stuff away and you know
it's getting a little tense and some
friends of a hey it scared you that
moment though this is just for this
specific specific movie the way that
moment play out I almost feel like that
was a self-conscious joke cuz I get the
sense that like this movie has a gleeful
Annis to it it's a lot more over the top
in the first movie like they cranked it
up to 11 first
the reason I liked it so much is there
weren't cheap scares it was a lot of
jump scares yeah their jump scares but
they're creepy as [ __ ] the reason I
don't like cheap scares it does it
doesn't stick with you you go home and
you're like oh you know it's someone
just you know came up behind him a note
touched oh my god that's not scary but I
feel I feel like there's only a few
cheap scares I feel like for the most
part there's some really good scares I
jumped a a good amount of times I jumped
too but because the cheap scares I
remembered seeing you you jump I jump at
the horror of having the cheap skin
there are certain those rent to me more
is like cheeky like like ah we're
talking idea because it has like I said
it has that sort of you know carnival
vibe to its proceeding and also I mean
part of the the the scariness of this
movie for me is just the fact that there
are certain things they brand that are
just unsettling and we it's like you
have this weird mother gender confusion
thing which is really kind of jarring to
look at and you have you know James Wan
is really good at coming up with these
things that are just creepy conceptually
and then creepy to look at and there are
some sheep jump scares but some of the
scariest things about this movie are
just in its concepts and ideas
no yeah there was there was some good
like scary creepy parts that weren't
dumb scares worried it gave me chills
like we were talking about earlier the
mother the makeup when she completely
turned that scared the crap outta me oh
and the mother right before she slapped
Rose Byrne the whole moment yeah like
just watching that whole thing it's so
scary yeah see that's a good scare
that's that's creepy I think when's she
gonna explode yeah yeah and then also
there was another part when was the
kid's name Dalton yeah when he has the
the cannon and he's talking to somebody
and then this person kind of like runs
out and she looks screwed up Oh scary I
don't again I would start piling on okay
before that like she's kind of in the
corner like shaking and like you can
tell something's just wrong and that
really scares the Karma and then the
ghosts come out that was that was a good
one now that wasn't a cheap hooker scare
alright that would be a legitimate you
know
high-class prostitute Cheers here the
thing that this movie is that they
change up the genre of it is you're
right in a sense that doesn't feel like
a horror film as much it feels wrong
yeah this one does feel more like a
thriller yeah but there is skin but
that's what's right I get your point
though at the same time where there's
scares into the concept of itself what
decision number two specs and Tucker
Tucker is like a fat person named
there's something about the way they
used them in this film where I
appreciated it because like that you get
it you hang out with them a lot more you
kind of get your little side adventure
with Tucker and specks on their little
adventure McCarl at the same time I
thought there was a little too much
comedy because that especially came for
comedy the thing I liked about the first
one I'm going back to the first one is
they didn't they had them in it and they
were the comical relief they were
because this movies so stressful you're
freaking out the whole time they could
say something that might not even be
that funny in this one I felt they just
tried to make them more and more funny
and it just wasn't working and it kind
of threw off the whole vibe of the movie
because it made it a lot less stressful
and they they weren't even that funny I
mean that yeah they had some good parts
yeah cuz it's kind of like a funny
paranormal investigator take a story
with them this is another element I
wonder if it'll play better the second
time around because it seems like the
vibe they're going for is much more
over-the-top and much more gleeful in
this sense and you know the reason
Tucker inspects work so well in the
first movie is because the humor comes
from the who they are as characters
they're almost like brothers they're
always having to one-up each other they
don't have funny dialogue it's it's all
from the humour of the situation that
this paranormal ship is going down but
Tucker still has to plot a bigger
flashlights and specks does and in the
second movie they don't play on that as
much as they do give them just more
funny dialogue yeah I love me right now
I'm just biased in general I love Tucker
in specs so I really enjoyed having them
on-screen in this movie but you know to
put the critic hat on at least on a
first impression they don't
quite as seamlessly with the story quite
as well because it's not comedy that's
coming out of the essence of the
characters so much as it is they're
making jokes yeah I mean don't get me
wrong I really enjoyed them still but
yeah I thought I thought calm the mood
down a little too much they're colorful
you know side characters in the in the
first movie and in this movie I'd really
dig that they gave them at least a
storyline to derive and to be
instrumental in and I think they are
important to the stories what decision
number three Rose Byrne I think she's
beautiful gosh I like her yesterday she
she looks like an old lady chuck in a
trap in a young woman's body that's she
just had some weird weird look to her
I'd still bang the old lady yeah don't
get me wrong she is not as crucial to
the storyline as she is in the first
movie but she still turns in a bang on
performance like she is really good and
part of what I appreciate about both
these movies is that you know rules
Byrne has been in a lot of things and it
would be easy to glam people up and I
really believe her as just a mom of two
kids with a husband who's going nuts you
know what [ __ ] is hitting the fan you
really believe that this is really
traumatizing to her life you know she
didn't you can cry over hauntings like
no there's something about her though
that that felt kind of like she was
missing from the film like when I look
back on this film like she doesn't do a
bad job at all might be I think she does
a great job with the scene she has when
I look back and I feel like she's barely
for some reason yeah I think again yeah
they didn't really need her as much to
set up the story because in the first
one they needed her to you know
experience all this stuff because the
first was about a couple and they're
gonna kid now you know like the grant
way more involvement you didn't go down
easy trying to scramble with Patrick
Wilson there when things got rough yeah
I love rough sex that's not the Virgin I
thought
rose Ryan's consensus a solid horror
movie sequel is the reason to see
insidious chapter 2 a solid horror movie
sequel is the reason to see insidious
chapter 2 they say I think a lot of
people are as gonna take what you see
here as an homage or a cliche and it's
really up to you or how you feel yeah I
like how they changed it up I like I
like how they just really continued the
story and completed it it's cool to see
a sequel where they're not just trying
to get a franchise out of it but
complete the story they wanted to tell
Jerry's Consensus funhouse chills are
the reason to see insidious chapter 2
funhouse chills are the reason to see
insidious chapter 2 yeah I mean it's a
bit rough around the edges in the first
movie but they bring in a lot of really
cool and really unsettling ideas and
they got really original with how to
approach doing a sequel to a movie and
it feels necessary everybody does a
great job with it so
you
or episodes are reasons to see because
he can't stop it just one
yeah once you watch all of our episodes
why don't you go ahead and follow us on
Twitter
we'll follow you back if we want to and
like us on Facebook and what like you
for liking us just in general we'll just
like you as a person agree to disagree
and at the end of all that stuff you're
gonna want to get updated every time a
new reviewer videos out so subscribe
click on them dicks that's right he's
got two of them apparently you might
also have a very strange twist that is
insidious
we'll say that that one we don't have a
dictionary on the bed so that sounded
good to me the second one was better
it's two against one I'm watching the
first one again when she was like it's
insidious looks scary too if you're
trying to spell it that's scary I want
to see a movie where Patrick Wilson is
half naked and Rose Byrne is half naked
well now if you had to choose one would
have to be you know topless and the
other one would have to be bottomless so
that's a a like a I would say Patrick
Wilson is bottomless uh-huh and Rose
Byrne is topless now I see I would go
the other way
you
you